sur le député de courson des départs de
soignants j'ai déjà dit que j'y croyais
pas je n'y crois pas et d'ailleurs
énormément de délire vaccinale
c'est pas parce que vous voyez un
infirmier une aide-soignante qui fait
une vidéo pour dire en pleurant qu'elle
va quitter son boulot parce que le
vaccin
alain a peur etc etc que ça veut dire
que c'est un mouvement collectif
c'est faux ça s'appelle de la propagande
je le déplore il n'y a pas de départ et
ça n'a pas été le cas non plus dans les
autres pays qui autour de nous on fait
la vaccination obligatoire des soignants
mais moi je souhaite vraiment qu'on
conforte les soignants dans leur
exercice qu'on les protège et qu'on leur
permette de protéger leurs patients